[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un magacín informativo 100 dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre liliana
valencia aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
representante de la organización mundial
de la salud en áfrica aseguran que las
naciones que están aplicando una tercera
dosis de refuerzo de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 están también retrasando aún
más la vacunación en el continente
africano y propiciando una posible
aparición de nuevas variantes en nigeria
15 niños que habían sido secuestrados en
el norte del país fueron entregados a
sus padres después de que éstos pagaran
una fuerte suma de dinero por su rescate
las autoridades nacionales piden a las
familias que se abstengan de entregar
dinero a los insurgentes
y cada 23 de agosto se conmemora el día
internacional del recuerdo de la trata
de esclavos y la abolición de la
esclavitud en conmemoración de la
insurrección de sant domènec en haití
sobre el tema hablamos con un experto
historiador afro colombiano
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos
hablando del coi 19 porque la encargada
de la organización mundial de la salud
para áfrica asegura que los países que
están administrando una tercera dosis de
refuerzo a sus ciudadanos están también
a trazando los esfuerzos de vacunación
en el continente africano lo que además
lleva a que el virus pueda seguir
circulando y que por ende puedan también
surgir nuevas variantes como la delta
que tienen efectos dilatadores en la
pandemia veamos
muchos pasan tanto global y
buster son los países de altos ingresos
han administrado más de 103 vacunas por
cada 100 habitantes mientras que en
áfrica ese número es de 6 pax y nayarit
el no vacunar a los grupos de más riesgo
en todos los países resultará en muertes
innecesarias y
fail xbox y dates los tres grupos de
nuevo con triste o risa ni testers no
nos cansaremos de repetir que además
aporta condiciones donde el virus puede
mutar lo que hará que sea atrás de la
recuperación de la pandemia a nivel
global en ultimate lic delay del global
recovery frontex pandemia el norte de
nigeria 15 estudiantes fueron entregados
este 22 de agosto a sus padres después
de que éstos pagarán una fuerte suma de
dinero a los insurgentes que los
raptaron en julio pasado sin embargo 63
niños siguen en poder de los
secuestradores que han hecho de estos de
tipo de delitos una constante en la
región
un abrazo entre un padre y un hijo que
se reúnen después de semanas de angustia
estos quince estudiantes regresaron a
sus hogares después de haber sido
víctimas de un secuestro masivo el mes
pasado de una escuela bautista en el
noroeste de nigeria
a veces no comíamos dormimos sobre el
agua a veces nos dejaban a la intemperie
el coordinador de la escuela aseguró que
los padres habían recaudado y pagado un
cuantioso rescate para liberar a los
estudiantes que se encontraban entre los
más de 100 que fueron raptados el pasado
5 de julio de la escuela secundaria
desde el bad y high school
sin embargo 63 alumnos más continúan
secuestrados el número de niños
entregados es menor de lo que
esperábamos los secuestrados eran 78 y
nos entregaron 15 lo que significa que
63 siguen secuestrados sin embargo
debemos dar gracias y estamos dando
gracias por lo que ha hecho y nosotros
confiamos en que el mismo dios que ha
sacado estos 15 niños nos va a ayudar a
encontrar a los otros 63 insurgentes
armados han secuestrado a más de 1000
estudiantes de escuelas en el noroeste
de nigeria desde diciembre de 2020 su
objetivo es pedir rescates a las
familias razón por la cual el presidente
muhammadu buhari pidió en febrero a los
gobiernos estatales que dejaran de pagar
por la libertad de sus hijos pero padres
desesperados a menudo recaudan y pagan
ellos mismos los rescates cambiamos de
información porque cada 23 de agosto se
conmemora el aniversario de la
insurrección de los hombres y mujeres
sometidos a la esclavitud en sant
domènec la parte occidental de la isla
de quisqueya que hoy en día conocemos
como haití a partir de estos hechos se
conmemora el día internacional del
recuerdo de la esclavización y también
la abolición de este flagelo sobre el
tema hablamos con el profesor e
historiador sergio antonio mosquera
mosqueda que nos contó el origen de esta
fecha y también sus efectos en la
actualidad
hoy baile
de agosto de 2021 desde el centro de
memoria histórica con tu manto estamos
conmemorando los 230 años cuando en una
misma fecha de
1791 bomba y otros valientes
descendientes de africanos libres y
esclavizados en haití decidieron
continuar la lucha que vence a una
calidad y tomarse el poder para crear la
república y a morir la esclavización
este anuncio se convirtió en la gesta
más importante de los pueblos
esclavizados en todo el mundo cuando por
primera vez instaurado una república y
vencieron nada menos que al ejército de
napoleón bonaparte que había desplegado
en 24 mil hombres para reconquistar la
isla merece entonces es recordada por
toda la gente negra del mundo y por
todos los amantes de la libertad para
cuán duro hemos luchado para sobrevivir
en este continente hoy más que nunca
estamos unidos a esta región de áfrica
control
del mundo vamos ahora esta burkina faso
en el oeste de áfrica donde el balance
de víctimas mortales de un ataque
perpetrado el pasado miércoles 18 de
agosto por islamistas radicales a un
convoy aumentó a 80 de estas 59 personas
eran civiles y 21 eran militares según
las fuerzas de seguridad del país el
ataque ocurrió en el norte de la nación
cerca de la frontera con mali una zona
del sahel que ha visto un aumento de la
violencia pese a la presencia de fuerzas
de seguridad internacionales desde 2018
desde civiles han sido asesinados y
también otros miles han resultado
desplazados en esta región que une la
frontera entre malí níger y este país
porque a paso
hablamos ahora de temas de la diáspora
porque la asamblea general de la onu
aprobó la creación del foro permanente
de afrodescendientes una iniciativa
liderada por chat en representación del
continente africano y por costa rica en
nombre afrolatina el objetivo de este
espacio será promover el desarrollo la
justicia y el reconocimiento de los
afrodescendientes a nivel global la
vicepresidenta costa rica- epsy campbell
es una de las lideresas de esta
propuesta
quiero celebrar y agradecer a todos los
países que aprobaron por unanimidad el
foro permanente de personas
afrodescendientes son años de lucha y
este es un espacio super importante para
el reconocimiento de los derechos de las
personas afrodescendientes en todo el
mundo un derecho que implica darle vida
a los compromisos del decenio
reconocimiento justicia y desarrollo en
un momento muy importante el foro
permanente será un espacio de diálogo y
de propuesta en un momento como este los
países han dicho que sí a esos cientos
de millones de personas que hoy se
encuentran atrás hay que celebrar con
los pueblos afrodescendientes este paso
que damos en función no solo de sus
derechos sino de la justicia y la
democracia de nuestros países hoy
millones de personas afrodescendientes
en todo el mundo tienen un poco más de
esperanza en el futuro
vamos ahora a sudán donde los camellos
tienen un papel fundamental en el
desarrollo de las comunidades que viven
en zonas desérticas esos mamíferos
gigantes son fundamentales para la
economía pero también para la
supervivencia en este territorio de
temperaturas extremas
desde que aparecen los primeros rayos de
sol
se ven cientos de camellos y con ellos
cientos de creadores y comerciantes de
todo sudán
[Música]
el día de mercado es un día muy
importante venimos de arthur es todo un
viaje el mercado de el molí es uno de
los mayores mercados de camellos de
áfrica
aquí no hay vallas ni corrales por lo
que los camellos tienen las patas atadas
para impedir que se alejen
comienza la subasta
un espectáculo increíble los hombres se
susurran los precios al oído un mediador
actúa como enlace entre el comprador y
el vendedor
aquí en la mayoría de los camellos se
comercializan por su carne que es
especialmente apreciada en el cuerno de
áfrica y en oriente medio un mercado
enorme que exporta 250 mil animales al
año desde sudán
de mi voto
este hombre de negocios es un
comerciante de camellos es su
especialidad sabe cómo elegirlos primero
hay que mirar aquí
hay unos 300 kilogramos de carne
tenemos que revisar cada parte del
camello los museos la joroba su cuello
y estas son las tres partes principales
que hay que mirar
pero no todos los camellos están
destinados al consumo también se venden
para el transporte e incluso para las
carreras en este caso los precios se
disparan
y pueden llegar a superar el millón de
euros por un gran campeón
los camellos siempre han formado parte
de la vida en sudán los nómadas y sus
caravanas han atravesado el país durante
siglos cabe decir que los camellos y los
hombres se conocen desde hace mucho
tiempo
según los historiadores
sus caminos se cruzaron desde hace más
de 4000 años
vamos con temas culturales porque del 1º
al 5 de septiembre se realiza en
colombia el festival internacional de
cine africano tica kunta kinte este año
el festival se realiza de manera virtual
pero también habrá algunas actividades
presenciales previamente hablamos con su
director ramón emilio perea quien nos
contó las principales cintas que estarán
presentes en este encuentro y algunos de
sus directores
yo soy ramón emilio perea leemos el
director del festival internacional de
cine y vídeo afro kunta kinte nuestro
festival este año se va a desarrollar
entre unas fechas comprendía del 1º al 5
de septiembre la temática que estamos
abordando en nuestro festival es el tema
líderes y lideresas affairs nuestro
festival va a ser de forma online
contaremos con algunas actividades de
forma presencial teniendo todos los
protocolos de bioseguridad en nuestro
festival este año vamos a tener una
exposición fotográfica
conversatorios charlas magistrales
vamos a tener un encuentro del espacio
autónomo de william o'neill congo y
entre las exhibiciones de películas
vamos a contar con la película
del director
rubén mon soy de guinea ecuatorial es
una película que aborda la realidad de
algunos boxeadores digamos en este país
y vamos a tener la oportunidad como de
conversar con de ello y finalizamos como
ya que nos llega desde nigeria porque el
joven artista o mal ahí presentó
recientemente su más reciente canción
titulada understand con un impactante
videoclip grabado en gana humala y
retrata escenas que conjugan la
violencia que golpea algunas regiones de
su país con la historia de romance que
se sobrepone a todas las adversidades
así finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días pero ustedes pueden continuar
con más nuestra página web france24
puntocom para que amplían la información
de américa latina y del mundo nos vemos
más adelante con más información que es
en estas 24
soy una bestia
viva las calles
fin
no no no
y
vicky condena
[Música]